salut on est jeudi et jeudi c'est le
jour de jeudi un petit peu ce que je
veux où je dis ce que vous voulez vous
et c'est pour ça que de temps en temps
je vous pose une question sur facebook
en général je pose la question le lundi
pour faire la vidéo du jeudi lundi
dernier je vous ai demandé ce que vous
feriez si vous aviez le pouvoir de lire
dans la tête des gens et là je parle pas
de mentalité je parle vraiment de lire
les pensées des gens instantanément vous
avez été au total plus de 150 à répondre
j'ai lu toutes les réponses je les ai
classés et je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait cinq groupes qui ressortait cinq
gros groupes cinq personnalités
différentes parmi vous la première
catégorie ce sont les chercheurs il y en
a qui cherche parmi vous il y en a qui
cherchent comme thomas qui veut essayer
de comprendre les femmes et je me dis
qu'en cherchant bien thomas tu pourrais
rencontrer quelqu'un je sais pas moi par
exemple altaïr qui cherche à comprendre
les hommes
du coup vous pouvez faire un duo un
espèce de binômes comme ça pour essayer
de comprendre l'ensemble des hommes et
des femmes à l'asie lancer les travaux
alexis par contre pourra pas être de la
partie puisque lui déjà ils cherchent à
se comprendre lui-même mais ça c'est pas
mal bien qu'il va écouter ses propres
pensées le mec il est malin et je
propose pour superviser les travaux de
thomas et d'altaïr aline ans superviseur
parce que elle déjà son but si elle peut
lire dans les pensées des gens c'est de
répondre à la fameuse question est ce
que les cons se trouve en 2e catégorie
mais pas surprenante pour autant ceux
qui vont se prendre pour dieu
directement il ya des despotes parmi
vous maintenant c'est clair alexis je me
prend pour dieu ces caches florian qui
est parti loin loin loin loin loin
puisqu'il veut aller lire dans la tête
du christ cosmique et il faut arrêter
avec sylvain dur il faut qu'on le laisse
tranquille maintenant on le laisse
tranquille
on ne parle plus de sylvain duriez
troisième catégorie très sympathique
aussi les malins là c'est la majorité
d'entre vous vous êtes des vous êtes des
malins 7 des malins forcément on peut
lire dans la tête des gens qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec sa marine à
l'appel cache son banquier et elle se
met au poker
le red deer normal mais là où c'est ce
clip ans et une autre marine se met
aussi au poker donc déjà vous serez
peut-être à la même table
faites gaffe les filles je pense
d'ailleurs que au poker vous ne pourriez
avoir de grosse surprise parce que quand
tu joue au poker est quelqu'un qui
débute il peut être persuadé d'avoir un
bon jeu avec pas grand chose
en analysant la manière de jouer d'une
personne j'étais persuadée qu'elle était
assez forte et qu'elle cache et un jeu
fort en fait donc elle faisait un espèce
de bluff inversée pour minimiser son jeu
c'était tout à fait le cas sauf que je
crois que sa main c'était froid pique
ebit de coeur qui avait rien pour elle
sur le flop même se disait que et j'ai
quand même un roi je pèse dans le game
j'écouterai les pensées des hommes
politiques je souhaiterais le bordel à
l'elysée plutôt malin montez socialement
la gamme c'est pareil fait fortune au
poker et au mentalisme c'est marrant
parce que je le dis c'est un pouvoir
énorme lire dans les pensées et voulait
tous jouer au hockey ou faire du
mentalisme moi je l'espère dans les
pensées je fais du mentalisme ya
peut-être des trucs encore plus souffert
non comme florian lire dans mes procès à
moi pour découvrir mes secrets de
mentalisme malin tu es pas tout seul
puisque clément on peut prendre ma place
aussi et dans votre bande à vous il ya
aussi louis alors d'abord il prend quand
même du temps pour contrer le terrorisme
et ça je trouve ça bien
bravo et ensuite si prends ma place et
enfin les deux dernières catégories il y
aller je ne veux pas de ce pouvoir là et
il ya aussi les les what the fuck
je finirai par d'abord ceux qui n'en
veulent pas alors il ya ceux qui n'en
veulent pas mais bon quand même si je
les ai je m'en sers un petit peu un
maylis en trois phrases
tu as changé complètement de direction
je ne savais plus dans quelle catégorie
maître didier tu as trouvé la solution
tu pars sur une île déserte mais
évidemment j'aurais de te dire je
viendrai avec toi mais malheureusement
six victoires les plus désertes
et oui mais didier d'une manière
générale je pense que quelle que soit la
question en fait que j'aurais posé
tu serais parti sur une île déserte au
soleil poulpe esata flipper je pense que
ça c'est normal fume l'appareil je veux
pas du pouvoir mais vous avez raison
parce qu'un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités je fais pas très
très bien spider man
j'en ai conscience yoann c'est pareil il
n'en veut pas il va se mettre un casque
en aluminium tu sais que c'est une
théorie qui existent ça pour contrer la
lecture de pensée théorique qui a été
développé par jane fait son cinéma sur
sa chaîne youtube dhimmi tu veux fuir
dans une zone sans cerveau ça c'est une
excellente idée tu peux m'envoyer un
message et quelques adresses à donner
les manifestations politiques aussi
parfois en temps il ya pas mal de zones
que je connais ou c'est sûr et certain
n'y aura pas de cerveau ne t'inquiète
pas certains concerts aussi plein de
trucs mais qui n'ont rien et on termine
avec la cinquième catégorie what the
fuck
mais pourquoi avoir pensé à ça à cette
question c'est sûrement la série que
j'ai préféré mais vous êtes étrange
quand même par exemple celle ci je suis
pas sûr que ce soit what the fuck au
départ devenir champion du monde du ps
peut-être une volonté mais déjà est ce
qu'il ya des concours du monde de qui
est ce que c'est vraiment ça que tu as
envie de faire si tu arrives dagher dans
les pensées des gens ou alors oui mais
tu fais inquiète 5 i/s de ouf
tutu fabrique ton propre pièce mais tu
mets dix mille personnages un million on
s'en fout en fait tu peux lire dans la
pensée gagner au loto alors ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle une fausse bonne idée en
apparence et une très très bonne idée
gagne au loto on est
tous d'accord là dessus mais comment tu
fais pour connaître les résultats je me
suis posé la question comment fais tu
pour connaître les résultats
tu lis dans les boules aucune blague sur
cette dernière phrase ne sera tolérée
est ce qu est ce que tu peux parler à ta
grille de loto est ce qu'elle peut te
répondre en fait je vois pas tellement
la différence entre lire les pensées ou
pas lire dans les pensées avec ça
monsieur une bonne idée l'isr début j'ai
trouvé ça cool le devenir unique semaine
s'achevant bien devenir unique semaine
d'ailleurs tu n'as pas besoin de savoir
lire dans les pensées des gens pour
mettre la tenue on t'en prie mais nous
une photo mais à la fin février lire les
pensées des autruches n'est pas admis
sur cette chaîne
on laisse les autruches tranquille moi
j'aurais trop peur en fait que les
autruches elle pense à des trucs de ouf
en fait depuis le départ forcé de grande
philosophe ou des grandes matheuse et
qu'on ne soupçonne pas ça chez elle
comme quoi peut-être il ne faut pas se
fier aux apparences
rémy qui est peut-être mon commentaire
préféré sur cette question j'adorais la
réponse parce que tu veux enfin rendre
service à toute une communauté au monde
entier en fait je pense que c'est la
réponse la plus belle qui pouvait
apporter je crois que ça pourrait
résoudre l'un des principaux problèmes
mondiaux existants grâce à toi on n'y en
aura plus en boîte de nuit pour
commander rémy merci merci à tous
d'avoir répondu à la question sur
facebook vous êtes nombreux à me
demander pourquoi je mets que la
question sur facebook pourquoi je la
mets pas aussi sur twitter sur instagram
sur snapshot surtout de ses réseaux là
puisque j'y suis je vais mais que sur
facebook simplement pour centraliser
toutes les réponses parce que sinon
c'est une galère de retrouver toutes les
réponses de les isoler pour faire le
montage c'est sûrement il avait de la
vidéo la plus longue en fait à monter si
vous voulez qu'on continue à faire
d'autres vidéos dans ce style là dites
le moi dans les commentaires ça me fait
très plaisir n'oubliez pas je l'habille
tous j'y réponds un maximum et puis vous
pouvez simplement de le faire savoir en
laissant un petit je ne dis rien vous
allez lire dans mes pensées
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais j'ai
ouvert toutes les vidéos au sous titrage
vous pouvez participer à ça c'est un
gros projet c'est vraiment chouette ça
permet d'ouvrir toutes les vidéos aux
malentendants très honnêtement j'ai pas
le temps de sous-titrés moi même là ça
ferait beaucoup trop de boulot mais
voilà si vous pouvez sous-titrés ne
serait-ce qu'une 2000 vidéos de temps en
temps vu le nombre con et ça peut aller
très très vite donc merci à ce qu'ils
font déjà et peut-être merci à vous qui
allez le faire maintenant
prenez soin de vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo merci de tous les
partages aussi vous faites des vidéos et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale blog ciao